ラブライブの時計当たりました。へへへ
へへへｗ
お前ら野菜食ってるか？
野菜食わねえとやべぇぞ
こんちは！
はじめしゃちょーです
今日はですね
お前たちバニラ好きか？
バニラ
ああ
そう、あの…
あのよくあるバニラっすよ。
ほら、アイスクリームにもよくありますよね
バニラアイスクリームとかね
バニラとかね
バニラアイスクリームしかないね
バニラっていうものがあるんですけど
まぁ僕もですね
アイスクリームでなんの味が好きかって言われると
まぁバニラって答えます
たぶんそういう人も多いと思います
バニラ
アイスのスタンダードと言ったらバニラでしょ
っていうかんじなんですけれども
バニラ好きな人多いと思うんですよ
結構
俺も好きだし
君も好きでしょ
君の友達も好きだし
多分、色んな人がね、バニラを好きって思っているわけなんですけども、
まあいいよねバニラ
あたしバニラアイス食べたーい
いいだろう買ってあげようバニラアイス
ありがとーたけしくんす・き♡
礼には及ばないぜミツコ
さあ行こうぜ
俺達のとろけるアイスクリームの世界へ
あーーーーーーーーー
って感じで
バニラアイスクリームってのは
女の子たちはバニラアイスクリーム大好きって言ってればモテるんですよ
バニラアイスクリーム好きって言ってるそこのお前ら
ほんとにバニラ好きか？
多分君たちは表面上のバニラしか知らないので
本当のバニラっつーモンは
クソ不味いです
うん、これ知らない人も多分多いと思う
俺もね最近まで知らなかった
今回こちら
バニラエッセンス
もう薬品っぽくなってるんですけど
これがバニラの本体でございます
エタノールとか入っててちょっとやばめなんですよね
アイスクリームとかプリンとかホイップクリームの味付けに
そういうのに使われるやつです
あーーー…。一回飲んだことあるんですけど
もうほんとにまずいです
何がまずいかっつったら
なんかありえない味するんだよね
だから俺が言いたいのは
お前たちが食べてるバニラ
っていうのはほんの一部よ
人間で言う皮一枚みたいな
お前たちは人間の皮一枚で
あいつは可愛いとか言ってんだよ
どう思う？
おかしいでしょ
なんで皮一枚見てあの人はかわいい
とかかっこいいとかわかるわけ？
それおかしいよ！
お前たち人の皮だけで区別してんのか？
なめんじゃねーぞ
本質を見極めろよ
お前たち大事なのは
人の足とか皮とか顔じゃねーんだよ
全部だろ？
心も体も
すべッ
で、おれが何を言いたいかって言うと
お前たちにバニラの本当の姿を見せたい
お前たちは裏の顔に騙されてるよ？
みんなバニラの
バニラなんてそんないいもんじゃないからね
もうなんか
出し方がやばいもん
一滴飲んでください感
あっ
ほらほら
いい匂いはするんすよ
いい匂いはするお前たちこれは覚えとけ
悪い奴らはな基本いいにおいするから
うん
あぁすごい
美味しそうな匂いがする
僕バニラ好きなんすよね
おっと騙されねーぞ
俺は騙されねー
バニラの本質をわきまえた上で好きと言っているわけですから君たちとは違いますよ
俺は今日バニラの本質教えるからお前たちはバニラの本質を見極めた上でこの先バニラが好きかどうか決めろ
お前たちが自分自身でバニラが好きかどうか決めるのはお前たち自身だから俺は全く手出しはできない
ただ情報としてバニラエッセンスがどんな味かっていうのをお前たちに教えようと思う
じゃあ早速始めようと思います
どんな味がするか僕はわかりません
飲みましょう
ブブーーーッ
薬だ
薬の臭がする
うわこれマジでやめといたほうがいい
身をもって危険を感じた
危ないよ
勘弁してくれよ
え？いまパソコンに当たった？